you think of lizzo delilah please shut  the door  oh my lord have mercy on the zone what  do you think  what do you think of that jerry is that  good for you bad for you how do you how  do you like that that [ __ ] will kill me  that would kill you right if a man had  an [ __ ] imagine putting your face  right between that that [ __ ] will kill  me  she's now promoting her new shapewear so  she's promo she has like shapewear like  well i give it to her though i give it  to her  because she's not ashamed to show her  body you know  why she be confident of yourself be real  you know  this is me you love me you gotta love me  uh-uh you have to love yourself yeah no  matter what how you look always be you  be yourself be feel good about your body  feel good about yourself to be honest  with you v if you can use the company  card i'd like to get a pair of these  pants  i want to get a pair of puerto rico  let's get them both of us  after the show we turn around